live from Beverly Hills California
please welcome the president of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences Janet yang
good morning everyone and welcome to the
Oscars nominations announcement it is so
exciting to be back live once again to
kick off the official countdown to the
95th Oscars on March 12th for nearly a
century now
the Oscars has been the most esteemed
celebration of movies in the world it is
a chance for us to showcase the very
best films of the past year and for
Global movie fans to come together as we
shine a spotlight on artists working on
both sides of the camera
every year in nominees in most
categories are chosen by their peers
actors nominate actors film editors vote
for the best edited movies of the year
and so on but the final and most
anticipated Award Best Picture is chosen
by the entire Academy membership that's
around 10 000 filmmakers and artists
living and working in over 80 countries
and now to present the nominees here are
today's hosts
2022 Oscar winner Riz Ahmed and the star
and executive producer of Megan Allison
Williams
[Applause]
foreign
everybody we've been awake all night
getting ready for this moment
and we're so excited so honored so over
caffeinated to reveal the nominations
for the 95th Oscars good morning
everybody Riz I am so happy to be here
with you you've been nominated twice and
you won an Oscar last year so I just
wanted to know did you watch this both
of those times
um I did watch it yeah but I didn't wake
up to watch it and the reason for that
is I never really fell asleep in the
first place there was just a lot of
anticipation and I know there's a lot of
people who can't wait for us to get
started so without further Ado here are
the nominees for performance by an
actress in a supporting role
Angela Bassett in Black Panther wakanda
forever
Hong Chao in the whale
Kerry Condon in the Banshees of inner
sharing
Jamie Lee Curtis in everything
everywhere all at once
and Stephanie shu
and everything everywhere all at once
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a supporting role
Brendan Gleason in the Banshees of Anna
Sharon
Brian Tyree Henry in Causeway
Judd Hirsch in the fablemans
Barry Keogan in the Banshees of in a
Sharon
and Ki Hui Kwan in everything everywhere
all at once
this is a delight I don't want this to
end I have to say it's much easier
working with you than Megan she is
tricky yeah
she's not around is she
you promised me that she wouldn't be
around yeah
no we should be good we're good okay
cool uh anyway here are the nominees for
achievement in music original song
Applause from Tell It Like a Woman
foreign
Maverick
lift me up from Black Panther wakanda
forever
not to not to from RR
and this is a life from everything
everywhere all at once
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a leading role
Austin Butler in Elvis
Colin Farrell in the Banshees of in a
Sharon
Brendan Fraser in the whale
Paul meskel and after son
and Bill Nye in living
and now the five nominees for
performance by an actress in a leading
role
Kate Blanchett in tar
Anna De armas
in blonde
Andrea reisborough into Leslie
Michelle Williams in the fablemans
and Michelle yo in everything everywhere
just two categories Remain the first is
achievement in directing and the
nominees are
Martin McDonough the Banshees of inner
Sharon
Daniel Kwan and Daniel sheinert
everything everywhere all at once
Steven Spielberg the fablemans
Todd field tar
and Ruben usland triangle of sadness
now the final category
here are the ten nominees for best
motion picture of the year
All Quiet on the Western Front mounted
Blue Notes producer
Avatar the way of water James Cameron
and John Landau producers
the Banshees of inner Sharon Graham
Broadbent Pete Charmin and Martin
McDonough producers
Elvis baslerman Catherine Martin Gail
Berman Patrick McCormick and Skyler
Weiss producers
everything everywhere all at once Daniel
Kwan Daniel sheinert and Jonathan Wong
producers
[Applause]
the fablemans Christy mccosko Krieger
Steven Spielberg and Tony Kushner
producers
tar Todd field Alexander milshan and
Scott Lambert producers
top gun Maverick Tom Cruise Christopher
Macquarie David Ellison and Jerry
Bruckheimer producers
triangle of sadness Eric hemendorf and
Philippe Boberg producers
and women talking
Deedee Gardner Jeremy Kleiner and
Francis McDormand producers
this was such an honor and huge
congratulations to all the nominees
okay
I hope you really soak up this moment
and enjoy everything that lies ahead and
in case you didn't know Saturday
February 11th is global movie day so go
see the nominated movies at your local
theater tell them we sent you and be
better prepared for your Oscar pool and
thank you for joining us and be sure to
watch the 95th Oscars live with host
Jimmy Kimmel Sunday March 12th
[Music]